I also believe that anything we can
accomplish anything with our two hands I
was playing for the Calgary Stampeders
we were playing the BC Lions I was so
excited two days later I got cut that's
a dream shattered I don't let this smile
fool you because this is 260 pounds of
kick somebody's ass around here
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn from actor
producer and former professional
wrestler Dwayne the rock Johnson and my
take on his top ten rules for success
vol 2 rule number 2 is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well enjoy
I think a lot of people work up to in
terms of a role model for achieving your
ambitions sure what is your advice to
people watching this going I want to do
that thing I love the way that you do
this how do I go about doing it why is
your golden rule I don't know if there's
a golden rule I can tell you this that I
believe anything is possible right I
live in the world a possibility and I
also believe that anything we can
accomplish anything with our two hands
and just putting in the work with our
two hands and also you hear this often
but it's really really true you got to
find something if you love what you do
and find and be passionate about what
you do and find something that you could
be passionate like it really helps you
know it gives you that motivation when
you wake up in the morning you just
earned yourself a dance with the devil
boy there's got to show you guys this
view it is spectacular of one of my
favorite cities in the world Vancouver
Canada and look I've dropped my blood
and sweat in this city wrestled multiple
matches in this city shot big movies in
the city but one thing that a lot of
people don't know that I want to share
with you guys is when I was 22 years old
I came to this city for the first time I
was playing in the Canadian Football
League playing my first pro football
game I was playing for the Calgary
Stampeders we were playing the BC Lions
I was so excited
two days later I got cut dreams
shattered sent home with seven bucks in
my pocket I was like wait no I got a
play in the NFL eventually those are my
big goals that's my dream you realize
that that playing in the NFL was the
best thing that never happened because
it got me here so my point is look
you're gonna get your ass kicked we're
gonna get this kicked out of us you got
to get up you got to have faith that the
one thing you wanted to happen
oftentimes is the best thing that never
happened so have faith and just keep
that in mind and keep plugging away look
at me do I look afraid when I was at the
height of my career in the WWE I felt
that for the very first time that I was
close to accomplishing everything that I
wanted to accomplish in wrestling and I
quietly
walked away kind of shook me a little
bit because wrestling was all I knew at
that time and I had dabbled in acting
but yet I also felt that I wanted to do
more and I wanted to achieve more and I
wanted to grow I wanted to grow as a
person I wanted to grow as an
entertainer and that I wanted to reach
as many people as possible not for the
box-office value of it but before the
connection and I had come from a world
where I was connecting with an audience
every night and I wanted that connection
and I wanted to not only be good as an
actor but if I made the transition into
acting I wanted to be great
I knew going in the cards are stacked
against me there's a shelf life to a
career if I just wanted to get by on
popularity I didn't want to be in that
position I wanted longevity if that's
the goal then I have to do everything I
could possibly do to know the business
of Hollywood from top to bottom from
acting to marketing to an executive
level to a producing level to a
directing level and just know it as a
whole that would inherently make me a
greater asset and I appreciate all the
people in the beginning of my career as
I was coming up who took the time who
took the effort who took me and because
I had to educate myself and I had to be
student of the game know your business
know your business and become a student
of the game and surround yourself with
brilliant people and go to work I will
beat your ass like a Cherokee drum I did
a lot of my growing up in Hawaii
and all my years of struggling as family
I was evicted out of Hawaii we're
addicted out of our little efficiency
force of booth force to leave Hawaii
my grandfather years ago bought the
wrestling promotion in Hawaii
if he struggled with it he died
struggling my grandmother took over the
wrestling promotion she became the first
woman promoter and pro wrestling in a
very cutthroat shark infested in the
world anyway why I just always
represented so much struggle
I started getting arrested when I was 14
years old a lot of stupid I should have
been doing I would at that time when we
got evicted out of our efficiency I
thought it was the worst thing that
could ever happen and actually at that
time it was but now in hindsight it was
the greatest thing to ever happen
because it forced me into this mindset
honestly of hard work it sounds like I
could do anything I will do everything I
can to make sure we never get evicted
again anyway that kind of mentality
drives me today I got a plan
might get us both killed but if it works
it'll be a totally boss story cool
well wait I need one more chance to
prove that I'm here the to be eight
maybe Greek god because that's what
other favorite part of the film were
kind of like is here is he not exactly
know which I love that's the new take
cuz you're gonna leave it like believe
in yourself that's the mission is just
believing in yourself and embracing who
you were born to be so by the way like
you're biracial and biracial right on
black Samoan like why exactly so often
to hybrids right and oftentimes like
when you're younger you know we
struggles sometimes the identity I wish
it was a little bit more like that or I
wish I wasn't different but you know
overall the message of Hercules how I
bring this whole thing back around is
you are most powerful most important is
when we just embrace who we are what's
going on
that is gotta go to work training and
some sort of physical activity becomes
my anchor every day try and stay focused
for me I got to get up at 3:45 in the
morning I do my cardio I'll have my
breakfast
then I'll go train and hit the iron then
I'll go to set if I could get those
things done before I go to set then I
could work for the next 12 14 16 hours
all right
empty gym the way we'd like it it's
Sunday just finish my warmup
it is family day its Lord's Day it is
also like that so it was paid on
respondents up to 7 all right Saturday
afternoon empty gym the way we like it
tripping over here it's late day which
means it's gonna be sweaty painful and
fun
don't get it come on
war left
one more good
all right workout number two I'm out
working all my competition right after
gym what we like it getting ready to get
after me
my favorite training partner
bring it home let's bring it out you
want forgiveness
I would inspires me in terms of what I
do and they're on TV or anything else by
the way any other platform the first
thing that comes to mind when I read a
script or a television project that
we're either producing or whatever
camera behind the camera is or the
audience like satisfy the number one
thing I think about is will the audience
like it is will the audience like this
TV show never put up for example fallers
will the audience like Wohlers will the
audience like this role or the audience
like this movie like in san andreas
well the audience like it and then
that's so that's part one for one beat
is well I like am I going to enjoy
playing this because look dude cameras
don't lie and as good as an actor as
if I didn't feel anything it wasn't
coming from here my heart my salt even
if it's a comedy or dramatic roll action
don't whatever it is TV digital
Instagram whatever if I wasn't feeling
it then you got some hair would tell
you are known as one of the nicest most
pleasant people in show business which
also really big boss like it's a lot of
things done so how do you balance being
nice and having to leave the Smackdown
there's a few things I always try and
find make sure that I find time every
day to be grateful for everything that I
have when you start off our day's
finding things to be grateful for and
inevitably leads to a greater happiness
so every day I wake up I'm a grateful
man for everything that I have but I'm
also very quick to make sure that when
something needs to get done and you have
to either articulate it to somebody else
and you have to set a protocol and you
have to set parameters and you have to
lay the smack then you got to do it in
the firm way I do in a kind way but I
also do in the firm way and when it
comes to laying the smackdown if
anybody's rude or if anybody is treating
other people rudely or unkindly I'll
happily step in and they don't want any
bit of this all right don't let this
smile fool you because this is 260
pounds of kick somebody my sole interest
and getting involved in Twitter and
Facebook was to motivate or inspire or
entertain I did yesterday what they
wouldn't such a day I can accomplish
what they can't and that it goes out to
the millions he's half black and half
someone knowing the culture loving the
dances he's very very proud of who you
I'm proud of the wrong because here ever
since our country I wouldn't be the
wrong
he's like common everywhere in the world
I really like that he came back to his
alma mater Tiger pride I think he's
pretty famous especially to me
Kevin Hart is buff as [ __ ] yes he is the
rock is okay - what's that phrase I'll
go for yourself
Dwayne could wear anything or better yet
nothing and he looks sexier than any
other man I'm spittin ah I appreciate
that thank you very much Jason Statham
thank you
hey Rock if you ever become a DJ will
you call yourself DJ DJ alright lay
that's so stupid
it's so funny I prefer ever you are good
just sent that comment I love it I will
call myself a DJ tripod mr. Motta can
make a suit out of Krakus material aka a
burlap sack with a corn husk and straw
woven pocket square and then let the
rock wear it
Dwayne you would still look hot as [ __ ]
like a tall sexy muscular scarecrow what
kind of drugs have you been doing dude I
appreciate the love you are smoking way
too much devil's lettuce right now
literally died this is the most
cringe-worthy [ __ ] on the Internet
do you not know how YouTube works you
maggot this isn't TV or one of your
movies die
Wow I know a lot of government officials
places
this is some cheese the rock has his own
channel I can't believe it it's like
looking at a grown up man who doesn't
know how to jump rope
no disrespect bro hey let it day stuff
and your bro alright and if I ever see
you out on the streets I will knock your
teeth so far down your throat you'll
stick a toothbrush up your ass to brush
them and then you don't know em do you
know I'm gonna do I'm gonna can jump
rope that's what I do
keep waiting [ __ ]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because David Union
asked me to if there's someone you like
me to cover in a future top ten check
out the link in the description and go
and cast your vote I'd also love to know
what did you learn from this video what
lesson really hit home the hardest what
are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick charta to the Josh
speaks thank you so much man for picking
up a copy of my book your one word doing
that collaboration on your channel I
really really appreciate the support man
if you guys haven't checked out the Josh
speaks go look at his youtube channels a
lot of great content there thank you
thank you thank you man and I'm so glad
you enjoyed the book I feel so honored
to be able to directly pass this video
along to Evan so that he can share his
ideas on what it means to live a life of
purpose which ultimately is all about
being your best self thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much loved
I'll see you soon
my biggest Hercules challenge would have
you know probably would have been when I
was uh when I was when I was 24 years
old
you know foot I grew up in a world of
wrestling and I love wrestling my dad
was a wrestler my grandfather was a
wrestler but then I fell in love with
the game of football American football I
played that and I played it till I was
24 years old and when I was 24 years old
I got cut from and I got released from
my from the football team I was playing
with in Canada it was a CFL team which
is the Canadian Football League
it's Canada's version of pro football
and I got released and when I got
released I had 7 bucks in my pocket I
literally had seven dollars in my pocket
I had no place to live I had to move
back in with my parents at 24 years old
man and that was a really sobering
experience for me I battled depression
at that time I didn't I had no money
didn't know what I was gonna do with my
life so that was that was my version of
Hercules in terms of battling back from
from something big and it also wound up
inspiring me to well get off my ass and
and get to work what did you learn in
w/e that really helped with your
Hollywood career now is it the stage
presence and the you know that sort of
thing and interacting with the crowd or
the fan thing what is it I think it was
all of those things I think it was
interacting with the crowd and and and
having like a live crowd acumen that you
have that helps you because you want to
connect with an audience it's exact same
thing of what Kevin does you want to
connect with an audience every night is
a different audience a different energy
I
the household my old man was tomato cage
teach me how his work and discipline I
was up a full circle attend
and wrestling world that I grew up in
professional wrestling especially in the
80 70s 80s where wrestling was a lot
different than it is today it was there
was no offseason obviously there's no
offseason and wrestling in those losses
and then and there's no offseason now so
I think having that mentality of no
offseason being in a constant state
training and trying to get better by the
way it's like look I've got a lot of
professional athletes who of my friends
UFC fighters - pro football players from
soccer players amateur weekend warriors
the greatest part I think about training
is I always tell this to people is look
you can't play football forever I played
for 10 years
you can't be in the ring forever you
can't be in the Octagon forever you
can't be in a boxing ring forever our
football field but you can always train
and get better and push yourself work we
gets work and I always enjoy working and
I love what I do in terms of make a
movie so I'm always preparing them for
some sort of hole that keeps me lean and
me the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon they
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]